head over to
losingmymind.com to check out our latest
song genocide support our work now onto
the show
I want to dive into this Atlantic story
a little bit
Democrats keep falling for Superstar
losers there's never been a better time
to lose an election
they're going to mention in the early
2000s the Japanese racehorse Haru urara
became something of an International
Celebrity not because of her prowess on
the track just the opposite her Haru had
never won a race she was famous for not
winning but for losing and the longer
her losing stretch her streak stretched
the more famous she grew she finished
her career with a perversely pristine
record zero wins 113 losses American
politics doesn't have anyone quite like
Haru urara but it does have beta
O'Rourke and Stacy Abrams the two
Democrats are among the country's
best-known political figures better
known than almost any sitting Governor
or U.S senator and they have become so
well known not by winning big elections
but by losing them that right there I
have to just
seriously name a Democrat Governor the
average person if you if you said who's
beta or rocked I'm like oh yeah I've
heard of Beto I've heard of Stacy Abrams
it's like yeah they lost they're they
they're losers and I don't mean that in
the insult in in the pejorative I mean
quite literally they lose and the
Democrats prop them up have them on TV
shows cheer for them and celebrate them
when they can't win no I don't know look
maybe maybe I really doubt they're gonna
win but let them try you know but
there's which more and then that crazy
looking uh sociopath guy from California
yeah yeah
I mean the left was so obsessed with
beta O'Rourke putting him on the cover
of magazines acting like he's a Ronald
Reagan figure everyone's gonna back him
you know 49 out of 50 states type of
popularity he keeps losing Stacy Abrams
they acted like she was you know this
great Queen she kept showing up and like
even on when she went on The View
everyone acted like she was the greatest
person to ever grace their presence and
it's like at this point they're not
going to win their elections they
probably will end up though getting some
kind of show or ending up on CNN or the
view or MSNBC because they're kind of
just celebrities now but they're not
going to be politicians I just this
article is so brutal never before has
such small-scale loser dumb so often
been sufficient to achieve such a
large-scale stardom apart from Abrams
and O'Rourke there have also been other
examples in recent years Jamie Harrison
made an unsuccessful bid for the DNC
chairmanship then an unsuccessful bid to
unseat Lindsey Graham that a second bid
blah blah blah mg MJ Hager and a Texas
Democrat lost a close house race I just
wow the Atlantic's pissed I'm willing to
bet that right now with the polls that
are coming out in the projections of
Republicans winning 54 Senate seats
there are establishment Democrat
activists who are fuming like what is
wrong with the DNC that they cannot win
elections they prop up losers their
policies are insane it's supposed to be
the progressive liberal party but I
haven't seen real Progressive measures
proposed like fusion power I you know
real progress for Humanity I'm talking
about not like sending people to Grand
you need like we need to be recovering
the carbon from the atmosphere making
graphene new industry all these real
progress movements that's the demo
that's supposed to be the liberal part
of the puzzle that pushes for the new
things and they haven't I haven't seen
it Trump won the first race he ever ran
right that he the first thing he ever
ran for was President he wins no no he
ran a bunch of times for his presidency
and then oh he went to their foreign
party that's right uh no no he was at
CPAC a bunch of times lost a couple
times as well primaries yeah yeah I
believe so sure yeah I remember seeing
him at CPAC a couple years ago
I think he had like maybe teased and
passed like oh maybe one day I'll run
yeah for president um because people had
asked him that for years and I think
they only do it also in the 90s as well
no I think I think that he was he was
going to run for the Reform Party and
then didn't or something like that in
2000. here's a timeline history of
politics although I'm going to read to
this and then get back to you guys
um but yeah no I mean I think that the
left has this view of like what a
perfect candidate is and they're like Oh
Stacy Abrams is perfect like she's a
super educated black woman she's massive
like that's okay
I'm sorry I'm sorry it might need to be
censored on YouTube but then someone
like Beto they're like oh my gosh he's
great great this is what the new Texan
is like maybe if you're from Austin this
is like the new Texan who doesn't want
any of their weapons anymore and it's
like no one actually supports people
like that even like you were saying
maybe what do liberals want it's like
they're not going to vote for people
like them they probably prefer a
candidate like you were saying maybe
like a Bernie Sanders or someone who's
going to be more uh more leftist and in
actions or something but these people I
mean they're just like swamp creatures
they just want to be kind of famous TV
personalities Donald Trump uh the famous
TV personality was talking about running
uh for president all the way back until
1987. he did run under the Reform Party
in 2000 he teased it again in 2003 he
was in the polls in 2011 but then
decided not to run 2012 he endorsed
Romney and 2013 uh and then he runs
formed the presidential exploratory
committee and then so he did actually
run for the Reform Party yes in 2000.
um Obama was so charming and like well
loved and just like he's very empathic
he felt like he had good relationships
with his daughters his wife loves him it
seemed like a pretty genuine I don't
like how he got co-opted by the military
industrial complex went down that path
but people in the Democratic party now
are mimicking him they're trying to
Identity politics they want someone with
his skin color someone with his clothing
type like Beto wears the same similar
clothes as Obama he has that button-up
that he tucks in he even uh does this
when he talks with his hand then you got
like Pete bootage who's like
literally uh sounds like Obama when he
talks and you're like it's just like
they studied Obama when they were
younger obviously and I think that's why
Biden picked Kamala Harris he was like
oh when I was vice president I ran with
a black man so I'll pick a black woman
to run with me and then everything will
be great will be like a great dynamic
duo but of course Kamala Harris is like
the worst vice president we've ever had
she literally doesn't prepare for
anything she shows up to things to talk
and then her her words just go in this
Loop and she doesn't actually say words
right even though she has speech writers
yeah I I agree you know it's really
terrifying to see that Kamala Harris is
the vice president but it really is
entertaining to watch her talk in
circles like her brain doesn't work but
she's too young for that to be happening
you know what did she she said something
recently I can't remember what it was
but she was she said something about I
really love some I can't remember the
Venn diagrams Venn diagrams that was it
I really love Venn diagrams just the
circles don't you love like what lady
what is going on I think she made a
10-minute speech about that one uh that
one particular topic it's funny yeah
it's like watching you know comedy she
worked really hard though to get to the
positions where she's at though yeah hey
Venn diagrams are pretty cool but you've
got to think three-dimensionally you
know you're not flat on a paper you know
she was she was there with Willie Brown
you know in San Francisco and uh you
know she she wasn't thinking about being
just flat she Goofs around she seems
like she's afraid of saying the wrong
thing which I don't want someone that's
afraid in leadership is positions I
don't like it and having them literally
said that well I believe it was
literally said this they want a woman of
color in the office like they said we
need a person of color an office like
it's the the dumbest prerequisite for
someone in a leadership Authority you
need the best person and then we'll
figure out everything else if they're
that great they're going to create a
genre of people you know the people that
want to be like them people that are
proud to be like them but you need a
great person to instill that you can't
just force it in my opinion you can't
yeah I think there were whole things she
would be like the great successor to
Biden she would be the person who'd
really bring in all of the Charisma
because Biden's so old he's boring and
he was running as kind of like this
middle of the road person now that's not
what happened he obviously hasn't been
like that but Kamala Harris was supposed
to be like the really good politician so
it was actually really disappointing to
see how how bad she really is especially
since she's our our first woman vice
president of course they don't Define
what a woman is so they don't believe in
that word but I believe in that word and
so it's sad it's all they had they had
gabbard but Tulsi wouldn't play ball
they were like we can't there's no women
of color on stage and Tall together
standing there with skin darker than
mine like a certain color you know of
melanin whatever the hell she endorsed
Biden though she played yeah she played
the game but I mean she had off the bat
she she torched Kamala Harris on stage
yeah basically ended her potential to
become the president if she ever had it
people called her the Kamala killer
afterwards after that one moment on
during the the presidential debates
where she just went right at her and and
this was an issue that a lot of people
knew about but were afraid to talk about
she brought it out in the mainstream and
there was no denying the bigger truth
that she busted wide open on the main
stage and that was incredible so I give
her a full credit for that yeah but what
makes me think they were good controller
though she she was she's anti-war yeah
and she stood up for the for for actual
individuals who were screwed over by the
system actual individuals who were uh
you know
messed up by kamala's policies in some
of the worst most atrocious ways and she
stood up for those individuals and
people that had no voice so Props to her
they said we want a woman of color as
Tulsi was standing on stage like there
are no women of color on stage and
you're like what she's I mean I'm not
saying she's African American you know
she's like a Pacific Islander but it's
it's nonsense the person you you vote
for the person who's going to do the do
right by the people of this country by
the country by its institutions and uh
and and without corruption in the bet in
institutions when they go wrong and so
that could be uh it could be Tulsi
gabbard it could be Pete booty judge it
could be whoever but um and I mean that
in a like identity sense I actually
don't think it could be booty Jackson I
think he's corrupt I think most the
Democrats are and I think what we've
seen over the past few years is that if
you're paying attention to what's going
on in politics you'd be like I cannot
support Democrats like even for Tulsi
Tulsi gabbard to have endorsed Biden to
me it's kind of like are you serious
dude like Tulsi is anti-war she's
anti-intervention she knows Biden is a
warmonger and she endorsed him
maybe you know I guess 4D chess or
something I think she had TDS at the
time she was so upset and dislike of
trump
but she also had the option of Bernie
but but we're hearing news reports that
Bernie was so cold and mean to her and
other people that she was just like
screw it I'm just gonna go with with
Biden here uh but yeah well if she's
like an example of let's say like a a
left-wing voter who's more Center then
they're going to be voting for us now
because she's Republican or at least
she's she's left the Democrat Party
she's endorsing these Maga candidates at
least and so it's like I think that the
left is hoping they can push people to
the brink basically say how much can we
push you to where you're suffering and
you still vote for us but we just can't
go off the edge well it's like they went
off the edge and so even people who run
for president as a Democrat are now
endorsing Mega candidates she also
endorsed Kerry Lake for governor yes
but she's also you know CFR thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time